Go to the red hot
center of what's
important in somebody's life.
Because that's where
you get the truth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In this era, most
people are skeptical,
distrustful of the news media.
Everyone is a journalist.
You gather information,
verify it, and communicate it.
Everyone has their own
version of the truth.
But there are facts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What I'm going to
teach in this class
is the importance
of human sources.
No one ever gives
you the full story.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Often, it's a mix of
truth and untruth.
The job is to go verify.
"I shall resign the presidency,
effective at noon tomorrow."
The President of the United
States is not above the law.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The human source is the
savior of journalism.
In this MasterClass, I'm
going to teach you research,
investigating, how to
gather information,
how to interview people,
and how to find the story
and build the story.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The purpose of an interview is
not gotcha, is not to catch.
I have a little
technique of sticking
this finger over
my little finger,
jamming it down so it hurts,
and it's a reminder to shut up.
And just listen.
Let the silence
suck out the truth.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
This is a time
we're being tested.
Let's tell the truth.
Let's not be chickenshit about this.
Break the rules- not
the law, but the rules.
This is the final
exam for democracy.
I'm Bob Woodward, and
this is my MasterClass.